[Musique]
vous voudrez dans ces circonstances
manifester mon amitié et mon affection
au président nicolas sarkozy auprès
duquel j'ai travaillé pendant près de
deux ans et dont je sais l'engagement
qui a été le sien pour notre pays
nicolas sarkozy reconnu coupable et
condamné à un an de prison ferme sous
bracelet électronique pour financement
illégal de campagne électorale une peine
plus lourde vu les réquisitions du
parquet la cour d'appel et c'est pour ça
que les cours d'appel existent dira le
droit et nous aurons alors l'occasion
d'en reparler alors que sept étudiants
américains réalisent dans une
bibliothèque
il est interpellé par une camarade
l'étudiante activistes fait référence à
l'inscription sur l'ordinateur de son
camarade qui signifie la vie des
policiers comptent puis cette bombe les
enfants transgenres le syndicat sud
éducation qui encourage les professeurs
dès le primaire a changé le prénom d'un
enfant si il ou elle le demande sans en
informer les parents appelés lors s'il
s'appelle laurent ou vice versa dire aux
garçons qu'il est une fille après
plusieurs longues minutes des changes ou
le
jogging tous
les deux étudiants abandonnent et
finissent par quitter la salle de
révision sur le constat je suis d'accord
avec zemmour sur les solutions pas du
tout mais le constat s'il s'agit de dire
que l'école ça va pas que dans la
société ça va pas que la politique ça ne
va pas que la culture c'est pas terrible
que on est pas du côté de notre police
ce qu'on devrait faire pourtant soutenir
notre police du côté d'armé du côté de
la justice ça fonctionne mal je ne sais
pas si c'est des insinuations ou des
accusations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus de cordon bleu dans les cantines de
lyon s'est terminée décision de la
mairie dès la rentrée prochaine ce bout
de fromage fondu dans la fosse viande
panne et ne sera plus servi le cordon
bleu c'est le fer de lance des produits
alimentaires ultra transformé il n'a
plus de raison d'être si vous pensez que
la france est un pays formidable avec
des régions avec des cultures des façons
d'être des façons de faire on vous
renvoie à vichy à pétain et c est donc
les gens se retiennent ils n'osent pas à
dire ce qu'ils pensent et d'un seul coup
zemmour arrive en disant mais moi je
vais briser tous les tabous il va
chercher dans l'histoire de la france ce
qu'il y a de plus malsain de plus
honteux de plus ignominieux pour le
défendre ce débat historique que j'aime
et dévoyé par des gens qui sont soit
ignorant c'est la plupart du temps soit
malveillant et qui se servent de mon
goût pour le débat historique pour
m'enfermer dans une caricature de moi
même dans son livre il est très dur avec
vous il dit bayrou ce bon judas béarnais
est un machiavel de cour d'école qui
monte des coups tordus de sous
préfecture en attendant un ours en
peluche à son effigie se vend comme des
petits pains de l'autre côté du rhin au
point d'être carrément en rupture de
stocks malgré son prix barrières quand
même 1 189 euros quoi nous allons
bloquer bloqué il n'y aura plus
d'augmentation du prix du gaz c'est à
dire celles qui sont envisagées j'ai ce
pouvoir de par les textes green le pen
estime que ce qu'il ya de plus
scandaleux c'est que grâce au tva et à
la taxe les français et tous et l'état
s'enrichit
marine le pen parle et nous nous allons
agir alors soyons très précis à des
écoutes fonction nous limiterons la rose
de l'électricité à 4% il peut être et
sylvie ce monsieur ne fait plus que 4800
7 mètres le mont blanc ces 91
centimètres de mon coeur de la
précédente mesure il est mesuré tous les
deux ans une chirurgie éveillé qui
permet de s'assurer que l'opération ne
prive pas le patient de certaines
assurances ici jouer de la musique